The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So, so far we've recently been
talking about examples in SET2,
and we're going to
continue to do so today.
So the example that
we did last time
was the plan photon form factor.
That did not have any
soft degrees of freedom.
It just had colinear and
higher degrees of freedom.
So it was a particularly
simple example of something
we could think of in SET2.
We'll start with a slightly
more complicated example,
this decay, B to D pi,
where we have both colinear
and soft degrees of freedom.
This was an example
that we mentioned
at the very beginning of
our discussion of SET,
and now we're going to see how
factorization looks for it.
And then we'll talk
about something
called the rapidity
renormalization group,
which has to do with
situations in SET2
where the separation
of degrees of freedom
is a little more complicated
than in the previous examples.
And we'll see that there can be
a new type of divergence that
shows up.
And that new type of
divergence leads to a new type
of renormalization group.
So B to D pie.
So there's going to be, in
some sense, three hard scales
of this problem.
The mass of the B quark and
the mass of the charm quark
are going to be taken to be
much greater than lambda QCD,
so we'll have an HQET
type description of the B
quark and the charm quark.
And also the energy
of the pion, which
is in some sense, related
to the difference of the B
quark and the charm
quark mass, will also
take that to be much
greater than the lambda QCD.
So just by kinematics this thing
is proportional to MB minus MC
roughly.
You could say,
it's the difference
of the squares of
the hadron masses.
OK.
So let's first-- we know how
to treat this decay if we were
integrating out the W.
This is a weak decay,
so B is changing to charm.
Integrate of the W boson,
run down to the scale MB,
which is the larger
scale here, that's
the electroweak Hamiltonian.
So that's what we'll call
the QCD operators, which
are the relevant description
at the scale of order MB.
Some pre-factor.
And I'll write the operators
in the following way--
a slightly different
basis than we
used previously,
or a long time ago
when we were talking about
this particular case.
So just a different color
basis, singlet and octet.
OK, so that's our
description, where
p left is projecting us onto,
the left-handed components.
So what we want to do is we
want to factorize the amplitude.
This is an exclusive
process where
we make a transition
between specific states.
So we'd like to separate
scales in the D pi,
and then we have O0 or O8
in this matrix element.
So we have two matrix elements,
one with O0 and one with O8.
And so, what could it
possibly look like?
Well, we already talked about
the degrees of freedom here.
The D is going to be soft and
the B is going to be soft.
So this is soft, this is soft.
This is going to be colinear.
And so, if it's
going to factorize,
and the soft degrees
of freedom are not
going to talk to the
colinear, the kind
of thing that you
would expect to show
at leading order in
the lambda expansion
is that you have the
following kind of process.
Let me reclaim this space.
So here's a heavy quark.
Here's one of these operators.
Here's the valence
quarks in the pion.
Another heavy quark--
this was B charm, U and D.
And there's an
anti-quark, and we
have to address this by gluons.
And if it's going to
factorize, then the way
that we should dress it
by gluons is as follows.
We would have soft
gluons here, and they
could interact, if you
like, between things
in the B and the D, because
the B and the D are both soft.
We can also have back and
polarization diagrams.
And that is going to factorize
from things in the pion which
are going to be colinear.
So we have our colinear
gluons and colinear quarks
inside here, and maybe
there's some Wilson lines too.
So we would expect some
kind of picture like that.
And that's actually going
to be what we do find.
But exactly what happens
at this vertex, what kind
of convolutions there are,
that we have to work out.
All right.
So what factorization
in this context means
is that there's no
gluons that are directly
exchanged between the B to
D part and the pion part.
So that it effectively
factorizes into a matrix
element that's like
a B to D transition
and a vacuum to pion transition.
So you can even guess
what kind of objects
this would depend on.
If you have something
like this green thing,
that's a B to D form factor.
So we expect a B
to D form factor.
And for the pion, if you
have something like this,
well, we already talked
about something like this
when we were talking about
gamma star, gamma to pi zero.
So for the pion, we
expect the pi zero--
the light cone
distribution, which
is the sort of leading
order operator for the pion.
So we'd expect a 5pi of x.
And we'll see that we
do indeed find that.
So the B and D have P
squared of order lambda QCD
squared for their constituents.
The pion is colinear,
and its constituents
have P squared of order lambda
QCD2, but they're boosted.
We can again use SET--
this is SET2, but we can use
SET1 as an intermediate step,
just like we did--
we talked about last time.
So let's do that again.
So match-- step one was to
match QCD onto the SCET1.
So there was some hard scale.
And the harder
scale in this case
could be any one of these three.
So collectively I
just denote them by Q.
And so what's going to
happen in that matching
is we take these
operators O0 and O8,
and we have to match
onto SET operators.
So let me call the
SET operators Q0.
I just there's-- because of the
fact that there's a heavy quark
in the way that that works,
there's two possible spin
structures here.
But we'll see that
actually only one of them
has the quantum
numbers in the end.
So we have heavy quark
fields, charm, and bottom,
that we can imagine
that type of operator.
And then the colinear part, we
can dress it with the Wilson
line, as always.
And let me put the
flavor upstairs.
And let me put in the most
general Wilson coefficient
that I can think of
for this process.
This could also depend
on V dot V prime.
I didn't denote that.
But in general, it will.
And it could depend on
any of the scales Q.
So it can depend on the large
momentum of the colinear
fields, as always.
And there's one combination
that's not restricted
by momentum conservation.
So there's one
combination that's
not related to these
scales, and that's
the, in my notation,
the P bar plus operator.
And then there's
likewise, there's
another thing with the TA.
So same thing, TA,
everything the same, TA.
And then this has got
a different coefficient
like that.
And so, what are the Dirac
structures just to be explicit?
The heavy one-- so the light
one is going to be M bar
slash over 4 in my notation,
the 1 minus gamma 5.
And for the heavy one, you
could have either 1 or gamma 5.
And that's because you
originally have a left handed--
originally here you
have a left handed guy
between the charm and the B.
But remember that a mass term
connects left and right.
So after you integrate out
the mass of these quarks,
you don't know whether--
you don't know the
chirality anymore in this.
So that's why you can have both
the possibilities 1 and gamma
5.
So if you put any other
Dirac structure-- so here
you could use chirality.
And so, you know that these guys
should be left handed still,
and that's why that this
should be this structure.
You know it should
be an M bar slash,
because any other structure
that you would stick
in here between them
would give you something
that's power suppressed.
Because you know that N
slash, when CN 0, and also CN
bar gamma [? per mu ?] with
any kind of P left or whatever,
is also 0.
So you'd have to have
something more complicated.
All right, so there's
those operators.
And when you do this matching,
it is non-trivial in the sense
that these two operators--
it's not diagonal.
It's not like O0 goes to
Q0, and O8 goes to Q8.
As soon as you start adding
loop corrections these two mix,
and then they give
you some contributions
to these coefficients C0 and C8.
OK?
So what you mean by octet
operator in the electroweak
Hamiltonian is
different than what
you mean by octet operator in
the SET1 factorized result.
But that's just a complication
that you deal with when
you are doing the matching.
This guy can be proportional
to the Wilson coefficient
C0F and C08, and that's
not really a big deal.
Any questions so far?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah
STUDENT: So is the point of
matching to get one of them
as being [INAUDIBLE]
to get the softs?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: So you're going
to distribute them--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I'm going to do that right now.
STUDENT: OK, so that's--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So then step two, field
redefinition in the SCET1.
And let me not put
superscript zeros,
let me just make it
as a replacement.
So then we get RQ0 again.
And OK.
For this guy, it's
exactly the same,
because in the Q01 comma
5, all the Y's cancel.
In the octet guy, it's not quite
that way, because there is--
because we do have--
in that case, we do have
the Wilson and lines
getting trapped by the TA.
So let me write out that case.
So we have-- so that's what
we would get after the field
redefinition for two operators.
OK.
So the next thing to do would
be to instead of calling them
Y's call them S's.
So, but there's one
more thing I can do too.
So these are, remember,
these are soft fields
and these are colinear fields.
So this isn't
factorized, because we
have contractions between these
Y's in the fields over here.
Gluons can attach
to heavy quarks.
So in order to factorize we want
to move those Y's from there
over to here.
And we can do that.
So here's how that works.
This is a formula that I
could have told you earlier.
So if you have a Y
that lies around a TA,
that's just actually
the adjoint Wilson line.
So this is a formula that
relates fundamental Wilson
lines and an
adjoint Wilson line.
So in the adjoint Wilson line,
you'd build it out of matrices.
If you like, they're like this.
So the matrix indices
would be B and C,
and instead of having
fundamental indices for the TA
alpha beta, you have an FABC,
and this is the kind of thing
that you would exponentiate.
But other than that
it's the same thing.
And there's just a color
identity relating them.
So because of this
identity, you can also
write down another identity,
which is Y dagger TAY.
This guy is-- so Y dagger
TAY is just the other YAB--
this guy's an
orthogonal matrix, TB.
So if you reverse the indices
then you get the opposite way.
And also, this guy is--
remember this is a matrix
just in the AB space.
So if I use this
formula in here,
that allows me to take these
Wilson lines here and move them
over here.
Right?
Because I can take
them, write them as a Y,
and then the Y is
just something that
doesn't care about-- it
just moves over because it's
contracted with that index A.
I guess I've got
some problems with
capitals and small letters.
Let's make them all capital.
So then not going to
move it over here.
And then I can convert it back
to a Y dagger Y if I want to.
OK.
So we can take this
guy and this thing
and write it over there as
HV Y TAY dagger HV prime.
I was careful about that.
This was the prime.
And then all the soft gluons--
all the ultra soft ones are
over here in this matrix element
and all the colinear
fields are over there.
So if you like, you
could say, we get this,
and then we get our colinear
matrix element that has TA,
but it has now no ultra softs.
And so we have a product
of colinear and ultra
soft things tied together
by one index A. OK,
so that's just a little
color rearrangement.
It's useful, because now
they're really factorized.
And now when you
take matrix elements,
the matrix elements
will factorize.
Oh, sorry, before we
take matrix elements,
let's switch to SCET 2.
So this is, again, an
example where it's trivial.
Because what we have
is, we have one type
of operator that
we're considering,
this weak transition,
and we don't
have a time limited
product of any type
of two operators in SET2.
We just have a single operator
that has both types of fields,
and then we have the Lagrangians
So this is, again, simple.
So we have one mixed operator
plus L0 colinear and L0 soft.
And those things are
already decoupled,
and so this is simple.
And so, we simply replace
Y's by S, renaming
it soft instead of ultra soft.
Really nothing is changing.
And these colinears,
we just put them down
onto SET2 colinears
from SET1 colinears.
OK, so to make it look
like I've done something,
I'll write it out again.
But there's really
nothing happening
except that now the fields are
in SET2, with the correct SET2
scaling.
So there's no Wilson
coefficient that's
generated by this stuff--
there's no additional
Wilson coefficient
because of that fact.
So these are SCET2 now.
And similarly for the octet.
So here we would
really have the--
OK.
So now we can take
matrix elements.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
STUDENT: What do
the coefficients
look like when
they're not just 1?
PROFESSOR: So they would
be functions of say,
plus times minus momenta.
So we could have--
if it wasn't 1,
what would happen is
effectively-- so yeah,
we talked a little bit
about this last time,
but let me remind you.
If it wasn't 1, that would
happen in a situation
where you had
something like this.
Some off shell field,
O, say like this.
So this is a T
product of two things
rather than just one thing
that mix off the colinear.
And this field here
was off shell in a way
that basically, this field
here is an off shell field that
would be a product of the
plus and minus momentum
of these guys.
And so, you could get
something that's effectively
living at this
hard colinear scale
below the hard scale
in the problem,
from sort of T products of
soft and colinear operators.
This is getting a
little sketchy, but--
since here we only have one
operator, that couldn't happen,
because you just
start attaching softs.
And colinear is been--
it's already factored.
So there's no way
that you could sort of
get this intermediate
off shell guy.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So this guy
would be colinear, right?
And the way to think
about this is like this.
This is just a
diagram that exists.
But then you go
over to the SET2,
and then you have your change of
colinear to the right colinear.
But this guy doesn't change.
He's still hard colinear.
STUDENT: OK, so it's a matching
when the material actually
has a different
scale than matching--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This scale would
show actually up.
And so if it doesn't show up--
so this would be
kind of a situation,
an going from step one.
And actually, we could
have done some examples
where that happens.
But I'm choosing to do this
rapidity renormalization
group instead.
Basically this happens if
you look at matrix elements,
and you could look
at matrix elements
where you have some
subleading interactions.
And there are examples
in exclusive decays
where you could
have this happen.
One example is if you
look at B0 to D0, pi 0,
just having all neutral charges,
then actually this will happen.
It'll be-- and it'll
be more complicated
than what I'm telling you.
But you can derive a
factorization theorem for this.
It's power suppressed relative
to the one we're talking about,
because the one we're talking
about always has a charge pion,
and it turns out
that that happens
at leading order,
whereas the neutral pion
process with the
neutral B and neutral D
is something that's
power suppressed.
Hope I'm remembering that right.
Yeah.
I am.
All right.
So number four,
this is an aside.
Number four, take
matrix elements,
and here we find actually that
one of the matrix elements
is just 0, the one
with the octet.
So let me write the
nonzero ones first.
I wasn't too careful
about the two different--
about this.
So there's some guy
that's just giving
a convolution between the
Wilson coefficient and 5 pi.
And then this guy, which
is some normalization
factor times a form factor.
These things are all mu
dependent in general.
And this thing here is
the Isgur-Wise function,
which is the HQT form factor.
And W0 is kind of the
kinematic variable
that that form
factor can depend on,
which is V dot V prime,
the labels on the fields,
and that encodes the
momentum transfer.
Which here is just
related to the kinematics.
So W0 is some
function of MB and MC,
which I'm not going to
bother writing down.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Just some constant.
I mean, it could have some
kinematic factors that makes up
the dimension, like some--
depends on my gamma.
Yeah, it's just some number.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK so these
are the singlet operators.
So in the singlet case, we have
initial state and final state.
In all cases we have initial
state and final states,
which are color singlets.
And these operators
are color singlets.
In the case of the octet, we
also have color singlet states.
And we factorize
such that we do have
a matrix element for example.
So let me just write
one of them, and no.
And this is 0, because
there's nothing
that could carry the index
A in this matrix element.
So the octet matrix element's 0.
It's important that
we factorized it
for that to be true, right?
If we had D pi, then we'd have
a color singlet operator here,
B. So we wouldn't have been
able to make this statement
in the original operator in
the electroweak Hamiltonian.
This would just not be true.
But once we factored it and put
all the ultra soft fields here,
that everything that's going
to be contracted together,
then we can make this statement.
We couldn't even really
make this statement
when the Y's were
on the other side.
We had to move them over here
to ensure that this statement is
completely true.
OK.
So color octet operator
is color singlet states.
OK, so then you just
put things together
and we can multiply these two
things to get the final result.
So if we write it as a
matching from the electroweak
Hamiltonian, there are
some normalization factors.
So grouping together
these factors of F pi,
E pi, and M prime, which I'm
not worrying so much about,
there's a Isgur-Wise
function, and then there's
a single convolutional between
the hard coefficient, which
is kind of like our example of
the photon pi on form factor.
And then the slight
[INAUDIBLE] distribution.
So we see an example
where it showed up
in a totally different
type of process
from the one we were considering
previously, thereby showing us
kind of the universality
of that function.
And then there would be
some power corrections
to this whole thing
that we're neglecting,
that go like lambda QCD
over those hard scales.
OK, so this is the
Isgur-Wise function.
And actually I did write
down what the W would be.
So this W would be that, some--
you can write it in terms of
the meson masses like that,
so it's the Isgur-Wise
function at max recoil.
And this function is
measured, for example,
in a semi-leptonic transition.
So you can imagine that
the pion distribution
function, or properties
of it, were measured
in the photon pion transition.
Is Isgur-Wise function
is measured in the B
to DL new transition.
And then you can make
predictions for this B to D pi.
OK, so that gives you an
example of how you would use
these factorization theorems.
So this applies to basically--
this type of
factorization that we just
talked about, it applies to a
lot of different things with
charged pi minuses.
Or you can make the
pi minus a rho minus,
and that wouldn't
really change anything.
So you could have B0.
If you wanted to
look at charges,
you could have B0
to D plus pi minus.
Or you could have B
minus to D0 pi minus.
And there's a
third one, which is
the one we were talking about
over here, B0 to D0 pi 0.
So there's three
different ways--
three different B
to D pi transitions
depending on the charges.
And what we've derived applies
to charge pions or charge rhos.
The neutral ones end up
being power suppressed.
And you can see that
kind from our discussion
there was kind of never a--
there was-- it just writing down
the leading order operators,
well, maybe you have to
work a little harder.
But effectively, the
leading order operators
don't make this transition
with the two charges being
the same such that
you could get a pi 0,
so you have to do something
more in order to get that case.
All right.
So questions?
STUDENT: Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You can if you want.
Oh, MB over MC.
So MB and MC, we're
treating both of them
as avoiding the same
in what we've done.
So if we wanted to some
logs of MB over MC,
we'd have to do something a
little different than what
we did.
You'd have to first integrate
[? O to MV, ?] treat the charm
quark as a light quark.
You could do that.
STUDENT: Would it make
the SCET [INAUDIBLE]----
PROFESSOR: It turns out that--
STUDENT: --analysis different?
PROFESSOR: --yeah.
So those are single
logs, actually, they're
not double logs.
And it's related to
the fact that you
have massive particles.
When you have
massive particles you
don't get the extra singularity.
And people in HQT
worried about something--
logs of MB over MC for a while--
and then after a flight of
doing enough calculations
they realized it was
totally irrelevant,
and you should just not bother.
You should just calculate
the alpha S corrections,
treating MB and
MC as comparable,
and summing the logs--
if you sort of think
of leading log as being more
important than the order FS
calculation, that misleads you.
Sometimes the sign
is even wrong.
And so there's sort of
a general experience
that something logs of MB
over MC and HQT is not even--
STUDENT: Just because
they're single logs?
PROFESSOR: Just because
they're single logs.
I mean, that's one thing
that makes it different
than, say, the
double logs that you
would resum in this process.
Actually, these double
logs are also single logs.
So you could decide whether
or not to resum of them.
But either-- whether or
not you do resummation,
this is still
useful, because you
could make a prediction
for this decay rate,
and it works really well.
All right.
You can actually
also make predictions
for these decay rates.
You can predict actually the
relations between the D0 and D
star 0 using the factorization--
subleading factorization
theorem.
OK, so let's move on to
our second topic, which
will take the rest of today.
And that's rapidity divergences.
OK.
So when we were
talking about SET1,
and we were talking
about loop calculations,
we saw that there
was a subtlety where
when we were doing
our colinear loops,
that could double count
the ultra soft loop,
if you remember.
So kind of
schematically, I could
say, that this true CN was sort
of a CN naive minus a CN 0 bin.
So you could do a
calculation ignoring
that, but then you
have to be careful,
and there's a subtraction.
And that subtraction avoids the
double counting with the ultra
soft.
So if you think about there
being ultra soft amplitudes
and colinear amplitudes, this
avoids a double counting.
Now, we never talked
about whether there's
something analogous
to that in SET2,
and we just did a
lot of SET2 examples
without ever even
saying those words.
So why it's actually-- for what
we've talked about so far--
OK to ignore this issue.
But in general, it's not OK.
So if we go back to our picture
of the degrees of freedom
in SET2, have this hyperbola,
and you could have softs,
you could have some colinears.
And then the example
that we just did,
it's like these were kind
of the relevant modes.
And in general, you might have
some guy down here as well.
So these are the degrees
of freedom in the SET.
And effectively
what's happened is,
if you want to think
about double counting,
you're sliding
down this hyperbola
so this hyperbola is kind of at
a constant invariant mass, say,
lambda QCD squared, or
it could be lambda QCD.
And unlike the
case in SET1, where
this guy lived in a
different hyperbola
here, to get between
them you would
be sliding down the hyperbola
at fixed invariant mass.
So that's a little different.
But in general in SCET2,
there are also 0 bins.
So in general, you would
have something like,
met me denote it this
way, CN minus CN soft.
And what I mean by this, is this
is my original amplitude, where
P mu was scaling like Q
lambda squared 1 lambda.
This was the original.
And this would be a subtraction
where you take that amplitude,
and you'd make it scale
like in the soft regime.
So it would be P mu,
lambda, lambda, lambda.
So that's different than
the example of SET1.
In
The SET1 case, we
would really just
be scaling down the
1 in the lambda,
so that they would be both
of order lambda squared.
Here we're actually
scaling down the 1
and scaling up the lambda
squared to a lambda.
And that's the right thing to
do to go from here to here.
So we're just taking the
amplitudes in this region
and subtracting
them in this region.
And in general, we do have that.
But actually that's not
the real complication
that shows up in the SET2.
The real complication has
to do with whether there's
any divergences
associated to that.
If this amplitude here
didn't have any divergences,
it wasn't kind of
log singular, then
you wouldn't really care
about doing this subtractions,
because then there would be
no infrared singularities
that you're double counting and
it would just be effectively
a constant.
And the constants
are always ambiguous.
So whatever mistake you
make in constants here
you just make up by
changing your hard matching.
So you don't have to worry if
when the colinear goes down
into the soft region
there's no divergences.
And that is actually what's
happened in all the examples
we've treated so far.
That when the colinear goes
into some region where it's not
supposed to have
singularities, that you just
end up with no singularities.
There's no log singularities.
OK, so, so far there's
no log singularities
from the overlapped regions.
But that's not in
general the situation.
And we'll do an
example in a minute
where there are
singularities that overlap.
And the true difficulty
here is the following.
If you think about what's
separating these modes,
you might draw lines like this.
Just to draw some straight
lines separating the modes.
And remember that
we're plotting here
in the P minus, P plus plain.
And that fixed P squared is
like fixed product of P minus P
plus.
So P squared is P plus P
minus, up to the P perp
squared piece, which
we're ignoring.
So you can think of these
lines as lines of constant P
plus over P minus.
And if I-- this is the--
so something orthogonal
to P squared.
All right.
So that would be one
way of thinking about--
so you need something
that's orthogonal to P
squared in order to
distinguish these modes.
And the real issue with that
is related to the regulators.
When you use dimensional
regularization
it turns out the dimensional
regularization is not
sufficient to regulate a
divergence that would happen
when the CN comes
down on top of the S.
And the reason is, because
dimensional regularization
regulates P squared.
It regulates-- remember, it's
a Lorentz invariant regulator.
So it's regulating
Lorentz invariant things
like P squared, not something
like the rapidity, which
is this P plus over P
minus that you would need
to distinguish these modes.
So invariant mass does not
distinguish the low energy
modes.
So rapidity, you could define--
is usually defined this way.
So exponent of 2Y,
where Y is the rapidity,
is P minus over P plus.
And if you look at
the scaling of that,
that scaling either lambda
minus 2, lambda 0, or lambda
squared for the different
cases for CN, S, and CN bar.
So it's this variable
that's really distinguishing
the different modes.
OK, and that's these
lines-- these orange lines
are just putting dividing lines
between these in rapidity.
All right.
OK.
So there's a complication that
dimensional regularization
doesn't suffice.
So you can think
of it as regulating
P Euclidean squared once you do
the Wick rotation, for example.
So it regulates-- it
separates hyperbolas,
but it does not separate
modes along a hyperbola.
It's a way of
regulating singularities
between hyperbolas, but
not along hyperbola.
So that's one complication.
We'll need an
additional regulator.
And we'll see that that
regulator will eventually
lead to a new type of a
normalization group flow, which
is flow along a hyperbola.
It's not a flow in invariant
mass, but a flow in rapidity.
OK.
So let's explore what
can happen in an example
where there are these
divergences in sort
of the simplest
possible example.
So there's enough
going on that we
want to make our lives
as simple as possible.
So what I'll talk
about is something
called the massive
Sudakov form factor.
So you should think of
it set up as follows.
We're going to
consider a form factor,
and it's going to be a
space-like form factor.
So it's a space-like
quark-quark form factor.
Q of the photon
here is space-like.
And we're going to think about,
rather than having photons
or gluons, we're going to think
about massive gauge bosons.
So this is going to be some
kind of Z, if you like.
It could be a Z boson.
And I'll just call
the mass M. OK.
So the thing that I'm going to
want to iterate is the mass--
rather than doing QCD, I'm
doing electroweak corrections--
electroweak corrections
from a massive gauge boson.
So this is relevant if we
have electroweak corrections
in a situation
where Q squared is
much greater than at M squared.
And we're not going
to be having gluons.
Instead we'll be talking about
these massive gauge bosons--
multiple Z bosons, if you like.
We could also put the W's
in, but let's make it simple
and just talk about Z's.
OK, so let's do this example.
So in the full theory, you would
start with a vector current,
say, and you'd want to
match that onto SET.
Before we do that, let's just--
let me just write down
a kind of full theory
object using Lorentz invariance.
So you could think about
the quark form factor.
And four massive gauge bosons,
this is just some form factor
that you can calculate that's
a function of Q squared and M
squared, and then
there's some spinners.
And so, really kind
of the dependence
is encoded in this F, which is
a function of Q squared and M
squared.
M squared is acting kind of
like an infrared regulator.
So this is Z boson, there's
not a soft singularity
associated to it.
And so, what you'd like to
do-- and in this process--
is factorize Q squared
and M squared, i.e.
expand this thing
in Q squared and M
squared, and maybe some logs
of Q squared and M squared.
So we want to factorize
some logs, et cetera.
OK, so what are the type
of degrees of freedom
that we could have here?
So lambda is going to
be M over Q, massive Z
boson over the energy
scale of the collision,
of the gamma star.
And if you just
look at the Z boson,
then it could be colinear
or it could be soft.
So it could be actually three
different possibilities.
And I could think about
doing this effectively
in a bright frame.
Just like we did earlier.
And then what you would have
is that the colinear guy
is like the quark, and
then the anti-colinear guys
is like the outgoing quark.
[INAUDIBLE]
So you'd be making a transition
in this diagram from N colinear
of objects to N bar
colinear of objects.
And you could likewise have a Z
boson which could be colinear.
Or you could have a
Z boson that's soft.
And you have a soft rather than
ultra soft because of the mass.
If Q times lambda is M, and so
if we want a propagator that's
like P squared minus M squared,
P squared better be of order
M squared.
That happens for softs,
not for ultra softs.
So that's why we have softs.
And the same thing for
colinears, P squared of order M
squared for these colinear.
So it's really an
SET2 type situation,
where the hyperbola is just
set by P squared of order M
squared.
We have our mode sitting
on that hyperbola.
OK, so it's exactly of
this type over there.
And the thing that's
new in this example
is that we're going to encounter
these rapidity divergences.
STUDENT: You mentioned there's
the only form for vertical
in your theories, is that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Make things as
simple as possible.
So you could talk about mixed
sort of electroweak in QCD,
but yeah, we don't.
Let's make it-- in
some sense that's
kind of just like mixing
a problem that we already
would know how to deal
with, with this one.
So let's just deal
with this one.
All right.
So in terms of the
external court momenta,
we can therefore kind of
treat them as follows.
Let's just let them be
of a large component.
They're massless particles.
So this is P, and this is PR.
And these guys are massless--
should have said that.
And if you go through
the kinematics,
Q squared, which is minus
P, minus P prime squared.
If you square that, you just
find it to P minus P plus.
And we're just effectively,
if we pick the bright frame--
which is what
we're going to do--
each one of those is
separately keep going at prime.
Call it bar.
Each one of those is
separately Q. The large--
these guys are just fixed--
both would be Q. All right.
So we could factor
is this current
with these degrees of freedom.
The quarks are colinear.
So at lowest order they've
just become a CN and a CN bar.
And then we have to address
that with Wilson lines.
And we know how to do that.
So let me just break
down the answer.
We could again
follow our procedure
of going through
SCET1, but it's now
so familiar we just
know what to write down.
OK.
So the current would
look like that.
And I'm not to worry too much
about the Dirac structure.
So I won't worry, for
example, about gamma fives.
And we could put
that in, it's easy.
So that's the leading
order current,
and then we'd have
leading order Lagrangians,
and we need to
start calculating.
And if we calculate what you
would expect from a major
from that is, you'd expect that
F of Q squared and M squared
is going to split up--
given the degrees
of freedom we have
into some kind of
hard function--
and then some kind of amplitude
for the colinear parts,
and then some kind of
amplitude for the soft part.
OK, so you'd expect some hard
times colinear factorization
of the form factor.
And this is what we'll be after.
So it's always good to
sort of have an idea
where you're going.
And that's where we're going.
So let's consider just
one loop diagrams.
And it suffices, in
order to make the point,
just to consider the
most singular one.
So I'm going to consider--
so there's various
loop intervals
that you could have to do
when you're doing the diagrams
if they're fermions.
Let's just take
the simplest, which
is a scalar loop interval.
And I'm going to contrast how
that scalar loop interval would
look if you were
doing the full theory
calculation with how it would
look in the effective theory.
And then we'll see where
the divergences come from.
So you can think about
this as kind of--
the piece where the numerator
is independent of the loop
momenta, so the numerator
just factors out.
OK, so if I took our vertex
triangle diagram over there,
then a piece of it-- where
the numerator is trivial
and factors out--
would look like this interval.
So let's just study this guy.
If we did this interval
in the full theory,
this would be both
UV and IR finite.
So this is just
giving us some result
that involves logs of Q
squared over M squared.
So it does have double logs
of Q squared over M squared,
and single logs of Q
squared over M squared.
But it's perfectly--
there's no 1 over epsilons.
So now let's see what--
let's think about what would
happen in the effective theory.
So we have a kind of analogous
loop interval for colinear,
where the gauge
boson is colinear.
There's some numerator
that again I'm
not going to worry about.
If this numerator is constant,
it doesn't-- it's effectively
the same constant.
In the case of the-- if
you take the leading order
numerator in the
full theory, it'll
be the leading order numerator
the effective theory as well.
But the denominators do change.
And so, if we took
the N colinear,
then yeah, so this
guy doesn't change.
Because that's just like
saying P minus and K are--
P minus and K minus
are the same size.
But this guy does change.
OK, so this guy would be K minus
P bar plus, because K minus is
big and B plus is big.
Both of these are big.
So both of those are
big in this diagram.
And so that's effectively
the Wilson line diagram.
OK, where the propagator
here was off shell,
got integrated out,
and just became iconal.
And the K squared is
smaller, so we don't keep it
in a leading order term.
And then analogously, for
IN bar, it's the other way.
So both of these are big,
and this one remains.
And then they're soft.
And in the soft
case, what happens
is that both of the propagators
end up being iconal.
And in our SET operator,
that's a diagram where
we have our colinear lines,
and then we have kind
of a self contraction of the S.
But we're taking
an SN with an SN--
we have a contraction
that's like this.
We have two of
the Wilson lines--
soft Wilson lines that are
sitting in that operator.
That's a non-zero contraction.
That would lead to a
diagram like-- that
would lead to this amplitude.
All right.
I'm going to leave
a little space here,
because I'm going to add
something in a minute.
All right.
So how do we see that there's
a problem with these intervals
that they're not
regulated by dim reg?
Well, you could look
at the soft integral
and you could just do the perp.
The perp is only showing up in
this K squared minus M squared.
So you would get
something by doing that.
And so, if we do the
perp with dim reg and IS,
we would end up
proportional to something
that's DK plus DK minus K
plus K minus, minus M squared
to the some power of
epsilon, divided still
by the factors of
K plus and K minus.
So you see that the invariant
mass is being regulated.
We just did the perp.
Perp is gone.
Plus times minus
is being regulated,
because plus times minus-- if
plus times minus grows larger,
or goes small, and
regulated by this epsilon--
but either one, plus going large
or minus going large, or plus
going small minus going small,
with plus and times minus fixed
is not regulated.
And that's the
rapidity divergence.
If the invariant mass is
fixed and K plus over K
minus goes large or small.
So let me write it as K
minus over K plus going to 0,
or going to infinity.
Let me say, with K plus
times K minus fixed, then
it diverges as
these things happen.
And if you think
about what's happening
in our picture over there
within these limits,
it's exactly a situation
where this X here would
be sliding up or sliding down.
So in one of these limits, this
one's going towards the CN bar,
and this one would
be going towards CN.
So it's exactly a region where
you would be overlapping--
sliding down the hyperbola.
And the interval has
log singularities.
So this is exactly
a situation where
we can't ignore the overlaps
and we have to worry about them.
OK so we need another regulator.
Dim reg is not enough.
We have to do something else.
So what could we do?
So there's lots of different
things that you could do.
One thing is, you could
just sort of put it
in some plus something in
these denominators-- that's
called the delta
regulated, K plus,
plus delta-- that's one choice.
We'll do something a little
bit more dim reg-like.
Which makes it sort of easier to
think about the renormalization
group.
So one choice for an additional
regulator is the following.
So if you think about where
these divergences came from,
they came from the Wilson lines.
So what you really need to do
is regulate the Wilson lines.
And you can do that as follows.
Let me write out
the Wilson lines
in our kind of momentum
space notation.
So we have some N dot P type
momentum for the soft Wilson
line, and an N dot AS field.
And really, it's this one over
this iconal denominator that's
giving rise to these
denominators here
that are giving rise
to the singularity.
So if we want to
regulate that singularity
we need to add something, and
we could do that as follows.
So this is the
regulator we'll pick.
And I'll just write everything
as kind of a momentum operator.
So I've just tucked
the Z momentum in
and raised it to some power.
So PZ is the difference
between P minus and P plus.
And that seems
kind of arbitrary,
but that'll do the job for us.
You can motivate why
you want to do PZ--
so this is 2PZ actually.
You can motivate why you want
to do PZ rather than something
else in the following way.
And it's a true fact, that
once you have enough experience
you realize it's good to use PZ,
because PZ doesn't involve P0.
And the softs don't really
make a distinction between any
of the different components.
And if you put in P0,
something that involved P0,
that would be dangerous.
So this is nice,
because there is no P0.
So it's the combination
of P plus and P
minus that you can
form that doesn't
have the P0, which is energy.
And remember that
the polls in P0
are related to things like
quarks and anti-quarks.
They're related to unitarity.
So not messing up
the structure in P0
means that you'll be fine with
unitarity, fine with causality,
you're not messing up a lot of
nice things about the theory.
So if you do put P0
in, then you have
to be careful
about those things.
So if you just arbitrarily
put in some power of P0,
then you'd have more trouble.
And so that's kind of why
we're avoiding and just putting
in PZ.
For the colinears, we
can do something similar.
But for the colinears we
also have a power counting
between the minus and the plus.
So for the colinear,
we can still
make the power counting OK by
thinking about putting in PZ,
but then just expanding
it to be a P minus.
And that's true up
to power corrections.
And we don't really need to
worry about power corrections
when we're regulating
these divergences.
So it's just putting
in the large momentum.
And so W written in
a similar notation.
So I'll explain what the
other things in this formula
are in a minute.
But the important
thing for regulating
is that we have some factor.
In this case, it would be
a factor of N bar dot P.
STUDENT: Dot [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
STUDENT: Dot eta to bar dot P?
PROFESSOR: No.
It's supposed to be
an N. Looks like eta.
Too many variables.
There's the eta.
So there's some factor
raising of the-- again
the iconal propagator
sort of mixing up
with the iconal propagator.
In this case, it's
even more obvious
that it's just regulating
that iconal propagator.
OK.
So if we were to do that,
and go back over here,
and put the regulators
into these integrals,
what would happen?
So here, we'd get
an extra factor--
K minus to the eta.
And so, that would
regulate this K minus.
And these integrals will
also have polls from the 1
over K minus.
You could think about--
well, OK.
If we did those
integrals, we would also
have rapidity divergences that
are kind of the analog ones,
and the colinear SECT
are still the soft ones.
Here we have two propagators.
And so if I have two
soft Wilson lines, and so
I get two factors.
But I've conveniently chose
it to be the square root.
So it comes out kind of
looking the same here.
So one thing that is just a
part of this regulator-- which
actually I don't know
a good argument for--
is kind of a priority from
the symmetries of the theory,
you might like to argue that
that should be eta over 2,
and this should be eta.
But it's really
just part of-- it's
just a choice, a convention that
we've made, as far as I know.
There probably is some
nice deep argument for it,
but I don't know it.
So what are these other factors?
So nu is going to
play the role of mu.
We've changed the
dimension of the operator.
We've compensated
it back with nu,
just like we were doing with mu.
We're going to get 1 over
eta divergences, which
are like our 1 over
epsilon divergences.
And we're going to
get logs of nu, which
are the analogs of logs of mu.
And that's the sense
in which there's
kind of an analog of this M up
with our usual dim reg setup.
In order to have
a full analog, we
should think about
having a coupling.
And so, that's what
this W factor is.
You can think
about it like there
was some bare pseudo coupling,
which is really just 1.
But just imagine that
you're switching from bare
to renormalized, in order to
set up a renormalization group
equation.
And then this guy here, which is
in eta dimensions, if you like,
would have a
renormalization group which
would say nu D by D nu
of this W of eta and nu
is minus eta over 2.
Sorry, this is eta over 2.
So that's the analog of
saying mu by D mu of alpha
is minus 2 epsilon alpha.
So an analog statement.
I think this is OK.
So this guy here is
like a dummy coupling.
And the boundary
condition for it
after you've carried out these--
this is just to set
it to back to 1.
So it's identically 1, it's
really just a bookkeeping
device.
It's just--e it's a dummy
coupling once you go to the eta
dimensions.
But you just set it always
the renormalized coupling
is just identically set to 1.
And identically
setting it to 1 is
what you need to keep gauge
invariance in these Wilson
lines.
It turns out actually
that this regulator here
is gauge invariant, though
it doesn't look like it.
We've modified the
structure of the Wilson line
in some kind of way that looks
like it might be drastic.
But actually these
factors here are gauge--
still leave a gauge
invariant object.
So--
STUDENT: Can you write
[INAUDIBLE] space, I assume?
PROFESSOR: Not that I know of.
Yeah.
STUDENT: I think [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Maybe you can.
Yeah.
But it's not-- since it's not--
yeah, I don't know how to--
I don't know what
it would look like.
You could probably transform
that power, and it--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm sure you can
probably just try out
before you
[? transplant ?] that.
I'm just not sure if
it would look nice.
Yeah.
It might not look too bad.
Yeah, and it might
actually be a nice way
of saying what I'm about to
say in a less nice way, which
is, if you look at
the gauge symmetry,
why is this not messing it up?
So one way of
thinking about that
is just to look at
general covariant gauge.
So note, the 1 over eta and eta
0 terms are gauge invariant.
And you can think about
that by just going
to a general covariant gauge and
seeing the parameter dependence
drop out.
So for example, at
1 loop, you would
take [? g mu ?] nu
in the contractions
and replace it in
general covariant gauge
by some gauge parameter--
of general covariant gauge,
K mu, K nu over K squared.
And you'd like to see
it independent of this.
But this eta to the 0 piece
is kind of independent
of that for the usual reasons.
And the 1 over eta term
is independent of that,
because this guy actually
doesn't deuce any rapidity
singularities.
What happens is that if
you have an N dot K, then
you have a corresponding
N mu in the numerator.
And so, basically what happens
is, you get an extra N dot
K in the numerator.
So any time you
have 1 over N dot K,
you would get for this piece
multiplied by an N dot K
upstairs.
And so this is cancelling,
you don't have a rapidity
divergence in the
C-dependent part.
So that's why this is invariant
under the gauge symmetry.
And then, because of
this boundary condition,
the kind of cancellation
of the C-dependence
in the order [? A ?] to the
0 piece, this kind of works
out in the standard way.
So it gives you an
idea of why it's
gauge invariant without giving
you a kind of full proof
or anything.
So we have both 1
over epsilon polls
and 1 over eta polls
in general, and we
have to understand
what to do with them.
So here's what
we're going to do.
For any fixed invariant
mass, it turns out
that we can have these
one over eta polls.
And the right procedure
for dealing with them
is as follows.
First you take eta goes to 0
and deal with these new polls
that you have introduced
in your amplitude.
In order to deal with them,
because you can have them
for any invariant
mass, you actually
have to add counter
terms that can
be a whole function
of epsilon, where
you have an expanded in epsilon
and then divide it by eta.
So let me abbreviate
counterterm as CT dot.
Then, after you've done that,
you take epsilon goes to 0,
and you find your 1 over
epsilon counterterms.
And this is the correct
way of doing it.
And we'll see how that works
in practice in a minute.
So let's go back to our
integrals that I've now erased
and just write out the answers.
We're doing those integrals
with this regulator.
And I'll also make
them fermions,
so I'm putting in
the numerators.
We wrote them down for scalars.
The scalars where the most
divergent integrals actually.
I can include the numerators,
that doesn't really
change the story.
And I can include the
pre-factors as well.
And I'll kind of write things
in a QCD type notation,
even we can imagine that it's
a non-abelian group, just so CF
is the whatever
group it is, it's
the Casimir of the fundamental.
Whatever group our
gauge boson's in.
So here's the eta poll.
It has a whole function of
epsilon in the numerator,
and it's even divergent.
So this is 2 eta.
And then the rest
of it I can expand.
So there's going to be 1
over epsilon times the log.
When the log replaces
that 1 over epsilon
then I can start to expand,
and I get another 1 over--
when the log nu replaces
the one over eta,
I can expand this gamma, and
it gives me 1 over epsilon.
And there's also
some other pieces.
So over 2 epsilon
there's a log mu over M.
And there's a constant.
And I'm never going to
write the constants.
So let me read all the results
and then we'll talk about them.
So ICN bar is the same.
The only difference between
this is that P minus
close to P bar plus.
It was really symmetric.
And then IS is different.
So the 1 over epsilon--
1 over eta poll comes
with the opposite sign,
and it also comes to a
factor of 2 different.
And in this case,
there's actually
1 over 2 epsilons squared term.
So there's also a
double log of mu or M.
And then there's plus constant.
OK?
And so, you could think
about adding them up.
And what happens when
you add them up is,
you have 1 over 2 eta, 1
over 2 eta, minus 1 over eta,
and so that 1 over
eta polls cancel.
And that's exactly
what you'd expect,
because in the
full theory the eta
was something we introduced
in order to distinguish
these effective theory modes.
It wasn't something
that was there needed
for the full theory integral.
And so you don't really--
you'd expect that it's sort of--
that there's a
corresponding regulator
between the two sectors.
So that when you
add them together,
that the dependence on that
parameter is canceling away,
because it was just an
artificial separation,
if you like, or separation
that we're doing.
So if I add them up, 1
over eta is cancelled,
and so do all the logs of nu.
We have alpha--
I'm left with a log of mu
over Q, 1 over epsilon poll,
double log, some
types of single logs,
and some other
type of double log.
So it would look like that.
All the nu dependence
is canceling away.
So sort of various things which
we'll start talking about now,
and we'll continue
talking about next time.
So the rapidity 1
over eta divergence,
which we can call a rapidity
divergence, cancels in sum.
And of course, so
does the log nu's.
And that's as expected.
And if you add an
overall counterterm,
for the entire thing it just
involves the hard scale log
mu over Q. So if you were
to think about there being
some Wilson coefficient,
which is sort of C
bare is ZC minus 1, Z bare
is ZC, C renormalized,
then ZC and the C renormalized
only involve logs of mu
over Q, which is the hard scale.
OK?
And that means that our
hard function, which
is the Wilson coefficient
squared, or just the Wilson
coefficient in this case, is
only a function of Q and mu.
OK, so integrating out
the hard scale physics
didn't know about
the separation.
The separation was
really something
that we needed to do
in the effective theory
to distinguish the
CN and S modes.
And you can see why
we needed to do it
if you look at these
answers, because if you look
at the types of logs that are
showing up here, in this case,
we have a nu over P minus.
And in this case, we have a--
is it nu over mu?
Just make sure I got that right.
I guess it is.
In this case, we
have a nu over M.
And we also have a mu over nu.
And so, the sort of
right scale to-- in order
to minimize the
logarithms here we're
going to have to,
again, as usual take
different values of mu and nu.
Well, it's the same value of mu.
All of them are M. But it's
a different value of nu,
because it's the nu that would
need to be of order Q here.
P minus is Q. And the nu would
need to be of order M here.
So it's the nu that
distinguishes the modes.
So the logs NCN are minimized.
Or mu of order M, which
says being on the hyperbola,
but the nu should be of
order P minus, which is Q.
And that's precisely
actually where
we put the X in our picture,
if you think about it.
OK, so that's saying that you
have a large P minus momentum,
and we have-- and we're on this
hyperbola where P squared is
an order M squared.
So this is-- and it's
likewise for the other pieces.
So for the soft piece--
so for the-- say for the anti-
for the other colinear piece,
we need the same thing.
And then for the soft we
need a different value
for this new parameter.
So having this
regulator is behaving
like dim reg, where we
needed different mu's, when
we had different hyperbolas.
Now we have different
places on the hyperbola,
and we're tracking that
with the new parameter,
and that's showing
up in the logarithms.
And if you think about what
the logarithms are doing,
you can see that when you
combine terms, let's see--
if you look at the
1 over epsilon,
and the mu's are
canceling out, you're
getting a mu over
Q. Yeah, that's
maybe not the best example.
Look over here.
You have this log of
M over Q In this kind
of complete decomposition.
The way that that
logarithm here gets made up
is by having m over nu
and nu over Q. All right?
So in order to get this log that
doesn't have any mu's in it,
mu is not telling you that
there's that large log.
But there is a large log.
So there's large logs associated
to these rapidity divergences.
And what we'll talk
about next time
is how you do the
renormalization group
with the diagrams like this.
How you write down in
almost dimension equations.
There'll be an almost dimension
equations in both mu and nu
space.
So we'll have to move
around in that space
and see how it works to sum
of the large logarithms.
But I'll postpone
that to next time.
So any questions?
So the general idea
is really, as usual,
it's just that now we're
dealing with a situation
where there's two regulators.
And they're actually
independent regulators.
One's, if you like, is
regulating invariant mass,
and the other is regulating
these extra divergences.
And so, we'll be able to
move around in the space
without any worrying about
path dependence, for example.
We'll talk a little bit
about that next time--
in this two dimensional
space of mu and nu.
But you can see just from
looking at the logs, as usual,
you can see where
you need to be.
And you can see
that you need to be
in different places
for the different modes
in order to minimize the
logs of these amplitudes.
And if you do that,
then there should
be some renormalization group
that would connect these guys.
So there should do something RGE
that goes between these guys,
and it'll be an RGE
in this new parameter.